salvo buon pomeriggio
vedo molto carichi e allora ho voluto
mettere subito questa immagine strumento
di cambiamento perché abbiamo pensato in
una società che è cambiata decisamente
sotto l'aspetto sociale politico
economico anche alimentare di trovare
qualcosa che permettesse di influenzare
in maniera positiva
un'intera comunità e poi salire sopra
un'intera nazione poi salendo sopra
eventualmente l'intero sistema mondiale
allora che cosa che abbiamo identificato
come strumento lo strumento per noi è un
panino per quale motivo perché il panino
in tutto il mondo 2 milioni 2 miliardi e
mezzo di persone ogni giorno mangiare un
panino perché un italiano su due mangia
un panino almeno una volta a settimana
quindi ci siamo detti il panino potrebbe
essere uno strumento per cercare di
trasmettere dei valori importanti quindi
valori che passano tramite un panino
siamo partiti qui ci diverte giochiamo
in casa
vedete convito nozze ester e assuero
giorgio vasari 1548 museo di arezzo è
una delle più grandi tele che hanno mai
realizzato il vasari bellissimo credo
che in pochi hanno visto diciamoci la
verità ma che indubbiamente al centro di
quel tavolo c'è del pane
ci sono due panini prete piccoli quelle
cose lì ebbene quei panini perché sono
un simbolo il panino è banalizzato il
panino è il primo simbolo dell'uomo
civilizzato perché dal grano lo prende
lo cuoce e ci trasforma fa un atto di
cultura
l'uomo che trasforma il granulo ci fa il
pane anche un panino fa un atto di
assoluta cultura e allora che cos'è
questo viaggio che ci ha permesso di
intraprendere e giorgio vasari
un viaggio che vogliamo mettere in
evidenza come elemento di mediatore
culturale valoriale ho messo volutamente
io perché bisogna essere cattivi
determinati un panino o del pane con
pomodoro olio e sale che primordiale per
molti è quella cosa che ti ricorda
l'infanzia l'appuntamento la
condivisione e durante la primavera e
l'estate o la merenda del pomeriggio
e a livello italiano il panino questo è
fra i più diffusi lo chiede a chiunque
abbiamo poche cose che costino poco cosa
possiamo proporti un panino con il
pomodoro e l'olio e proprio italianità a
livello massimo quindi mediatore
culturale perché perché i ragazzi oggi
under 30 secondo l'indagine che abbiamo
effettuato anche con l'università non
gli frega niente dei cuochi stellati dei
piatti bellissimi rifiniti con la
provenienza di una chiffon sopra la
julienne
ai ragazzi non gli interessa ai ragazzi
dobbiamo parlare un linguaggio che
possono capire perché dobbiamo parlare
un linguaggio che possono capire perché
questi valori che sono legati al
territorio la cultura
l'elemento delle passioni delle emozioni
devono essere trasmessi su una
situazione che sta diventando gigantesca
è obesa qual è il problema
il problema è che noi dobbiamo offrire
ai ragazzi ma anche agli adulti
il concetto del panino come praticità
tanino l'omaggio velocemente non c'è
problemi non posso mettere in tasca e
direi la cucina in tasca come l'hanno
definita alcuni esperti gratificazione
il panino in questo caso usato il panino
con la mortadella chi non si ricorda il
panino con la mortadella mangiato a
scuola durante il quale la pausa delle
lezioni a metà mattinata oppure magari
il panino con la mortadella consumato
dopo una partita di calcio o di
pallavolo fra fra amici oppure il
concetto della tradizione la mortadella
come elemento tradizionale in questo
caso usato la mortadella ma può essere
qualunque tipo di salume la finocchiona
il salame perché no potremmo anche
metterci dentro altre altri prodotti ma
concetto tradizione quindi il panino a
dentro a sei anche qualcosa che può
essere di territorio e poi il costo
vista la situazione economica e sociale
costo chip costa poco grandi chef
stellati parlando con bottura tre stelle
michelin
mi diceva guarda a modena io sono
obiettivi uno dei cuochi italiani più
importanti eccetera eccetera eccetera ma
ad un camper in un centro dove faccio in
dodici metri quadrati dei panini solo 5
con territorio attenzione che costano 5
euro l'uno
in questo modo sto intercettando tutti i
giovani e vengono addirittura anche da
lontano per poter mangiare i miei
panieri quindi che sto facendo
sto facendo qualcosa che riesce a
combattere questo problema gravissimo
che c'è del quale siamo tutti incazzati
questo è il vero problema si chiama
torno grafia gastronomica c'è di mezzo
la televisione ma non solo ci sono di
mezzo tutte le banalità legate al mondo
ora dico impari queste pornografia gas
il più grosso il più pesante il più
odioso e se lo mangi nell'arco di dieci
minuti ci sono degli stupidi che
addirittura danno il premio nel caso in
cui riesce a consumarlo in quel
minutaggio il grosso panino ci
abbuffiamo colano giù dalla bocca
le cose e intanto diventiamo grassi
obesi i ragazzini non sanno i medici
come fare a misurare la glicemia perché
non c'è paragone non c'è metodo non
sappiamo 1 quale è quando è diabetico un
bambino di 10 anni
così mi diceva la responsabile della
diabetologia che opera in una struttura
sanitaria toscana
ebbene questa pornografia va combattuta
allora abbiamo detto marino come
mediatore culturale i ragazzi mi
ascoltano mi possono anche cercare di
seguire e di conseguenza abbiamo
realizzato un progetto una nuova visione
abbiamo testato banda piccoli chef nel
quale il messaggio è fare con gusto e
salute in poche parole di cosa si tratta
abbiamo preso dei bambini di età
compresa circa 300 fra gli 8 ei 14 anni
quindi non più bambini a 14 sono
adolescenti
li abbiamo messi a fare a toccare delle
cose semplici
le verdure i salumi di stagione dandogli
già tagliati e cercando di fargli capire
che potevano finire dentro al panino
inteso come una focaccia come un panino
come un orticello a seconda di come lo
si vuol chiamare il cu laccio come
chiamano nell'area della della romagna
tagliato in due lì dentro ci metti che
ti pare e abbiamo visto che questi
bambini all'inizio del progetto gli
dicevamo scusa qual era la verdura di
stagione in questo periodo quasi esso
non lo sapeva qual è la verdura di
stagione in questo per nessuno
con il progetto con gli incontri che
erano però condivisi con la
collaborazione anche la presenza delle
mamme e dei babbi e quindi dei genitori
abbiamo visto che a fare con gusto e
salute bambini si appassionava
e gli piaceva elaborare il panino
perfetto c'è un panino che avesse delle
caratteristiche che insieme ai vari
esperti abbiamo identificato doveva
essere pane di qualità quindi un pane
fatto secondo le cotture ideali con il
lievito madre non entravamo troppo nei
tecnicismi però un pane fatto vero non
un pane che contenesse la plastica come
avviene oggi nel 90 per cento dei casi
di pane consumato no non va bene perché
costa poco di più è economico ma può
cambiare l'approccio di carattere
sensoriale e di salute di una persona
quindi pane che provenisse da un fornaio
la scelta del pane era come si voleva 2
concetto delle verdure non sminuzzate se
ai bambini o alla gente diamoli emilio e
verdure sminuzzate a pezzettini non gli
piacciono perché i bambini o la gente
che vuole mangiare qualcosa la vuole
della forma
come si vede bella grande consistente
perché l'elemento visivo centrale
tre le salse non il catch up down euro
12 litri di ketchup
ma la passata di pomodoro fatta
semplicemente che costa comunque non
tanto ma almeno è passata di pomodoro
che la tua vita tutte le parti 4 la
farcitura non la farcitura
dell'hamburger da circa 50 centesimi
della grande industria americana ma un
hamburger fatto con animali allevati
normalmente nel territorio con
attenzione non dico la chianina non mi
voglio esporre a tali livelli ma un
animale vero non pompato spinto
ingrassato e un hamburger del genere va
a costare una cifra decente non è che
costa caro perché per quanto ce ne è lì
dentro non è così influente nel costo
finale sono poche decine di centesimi
ma stiamo scherzando 70 per cento il
primo perfetto dovrebbe essere il 70
grammi di pane e 70 grammi di farciture
che è successo noi allora abbiamo
pensato che tutti possiamo incidere sul
cambiamento ciascuno anche voi salate a
casa almeno una volta a settimana
una volta non dico sette volte mille
volte con un ragazzo under 14 ma anche
con 20 se andate una volta a settimana a
comprare dei prodotti
non dico nei mercati di campagna amica o
di altre aziende che non non cito non
importa prova il mercato una volta a
settimana prodotto stagionale con la
possibilità di compilare insieme il
panino farlo fisicamente assemblarlo in
casa è un momento di condivisione
sociale non costa niente ed è fattibile
non è difficile e questo a livello
esponenziale abbiamo visto che se viene
fatto
mano a mano che si sale si diventa
virtuosi perché sia lapresse apprezza le
cose concrete non ci si fa fregare non
si va a consumare qualcosa che è lontano
allora noi abbiamo studiato il graal eco
chiudo con questa immagine
l'idea del graal contenitore del panino
perfetto proprio perfetto non esiste
ognuno ha il suo perché la prima parola
dell'acronimo gran gusto
ognuno al suo gusto per me il mio
pallino può essere uno per un'altra
persona può essere l'opposto ed è
legittimo quindi gusto è personalizzato
ricerca la ricerca di prodotti del
territorio
se possibile virtuosi che appartengano
ad una filiera virtuosa ma se non si
vuole comprare quelli virtuosi ma almeno
ricercare prodotti di qualità arte
bianca un pare che sia fatto secondo le
logiche del pane usando la farina non
usando i problemi della plastica e della
gomma che metti in con le abitazioni
false altezza della esserci rapporto fra
la farcitura abbiamo detto ai bambini
anche a più grandi farcitura e pane le
due pezzi di pane devono essere la
stessa altezza è un fatto tecnico
farcitura e il due pezzi di pane nella
stessa proporzione non mi sembra che sia
complicato linea nutrizionale è centrale
perché abbiamo visto con i nutrizionisti
che anche un panino tanto aberrato dagli
anni ottanta eccetera per i paninari per
tutto il concetto industriale può essere
bilanciato quindi comunque passiamo dei
messaggi non costa niente è facile mio
panino perfetto e io ve lo dico
pane e cioccolata che dovete farlo però
a me la nonna triturava le nocciole e
poi vela faceva così e io ho questi
ricordi per me il pane e cioccolata ma
chiudo col panino perfetto presumibile
sotto l'aspetto storico di giorgio
vasari perché in quell'epoca erano dei
piatti più importanti
delle carni più gustose che si poteva
mettere ed era esattamente il panino con
la porchetta e di questa terra
il vasari le porchette erano nei
banchetti di epoca rinascimentale al
centro di tutto e la porchetta era la
carne che veniva lanciata al popolo
quando si andava a chiudere a fare una
grande festa
grazie